[Music]
is it possible for me to be creative if
i'm not a creative person
this is interesting because i do believe
there is such a thing as talent there's
someone who you know kevin durant has
certain talents that i will never have
he's also seven feet tall right and so
i wouldn't say that i'm untalented in
basketball i would say that i don't i
don't have the same
talent as him right but also he has a
whole set of skills that he's developed
over several decades and so
saying you're an uncreative person or
are you not a creative person is like
saying i don't have height well no
everyone has height
some people are taller than other people
and so you have a
height right like i'm 6'2 i have a
height but there are people who are
appreciably taller than me i think the
same is true with creativity i'm about 6
2 and creativity as well there are some
people who tower over me and they're
sort of in born creativity but it's not
an excuse for me to not create we are
all creative beings to some extent would
you agree with that yeah i mean i i
it's an interesting thing right because
it is only a thing that creative people
say what we call creative people only
creative people say everybody's creative
you know is that kind of interesting
yeah um
i i actually
i i think i reject the notion of talent
and and what i mean by that is i think
we develop skills as sort of
adaptive behaviors to life so if you're
born
super tall
you know everyone goes you should play
basketball or whatever you're like i
guess like you put in a lot of hours
because of a genetic predisposition
you know there's you know there's
certainly the biology and so
i think
um
we don't get to completely decide what
kind of art we want to make
i i like what parker palmer who's a
quaker says about this quaker author and
activist he says before i can tell my
life what i want to do with it i need to
listen to my life telling me who i am
before i can tell my life what i want to
do with it set goals i need to listen to
my life telling me who i am
there's nothing wrong with that looking
at who you are the experiences that you
had how these things made you what you
are and then working with those not like
consigning yourself to i'll never do x y
or z if you want to do something do it
but look at this stuff that you're
working with so when i look at my life i
go well i didn't play sports because i'm
five seven five eight and um and because
my mom told me don't play sports be do
creative things you know like it was
very anti-athletic so what did i do i
found myself um
painting and drawing and writing songs
because girls wouldn't go out with me
and that's a good way to you know vent
that and eventually get girls to go out
with you
um i found expressions of things that
were happening in my life and um i
became creative not because i wanted to
be creative but because that was my
response to what was happening in my
life yeah now creativity means making
something
so you learn we learn this as parents i
think
um i remember when my son was maybe six
he was at our breakfast table just
drawing
right and i go hey buddy you're really
creative that's amazing he goes what i
go you're really creative he goes what
does that mean i go
means you
make stuff
and i was like oh [ __ ] i don't know
from the mouth of babes you know and and
that there's that old picasso quote you
know um every child is an artist and you
kind of have to learn how to not be
creative you don't have to convince a
child
sing a song you know draw something
build something make something it is
innate yeah um human beings are making
things all the time yes we are creating
things now we have relegated a certain
set of activities that we call creative
which means artistic you know but elon
musk is creative in the sense that he is
designing solutions to problems that
people thought were
impossible to solve
that's creative so i would say
um don't try to fit into some you know
artsy fartsy box right because if that's
not your experience that's gonna feel
frustrating and don't try to be good at
things that you don't feel drawn to
i had a great conversation years ago
um
with an author whose name escapes me he
wrote a book called the talent code
daniel coyle
great book about kind of debunking you
know skill versus natural born talent
he said this to me i thought it was
really interesting he said uh we i said
how do you get great at something he
goes it's you know ten thousand hours of
practice he goes but there's got to be
some sort of intrinsic motivation
there's got to be what he called a spark
and i said where does that come from he
goes nobody knows
there's this kind of like spiritual
mystical mysterious element to it which
is
kids and human beings adults you know
all alike are sort of drawn to some
things over others and no amount of
pushing can make somebody love something
that they don't love and so my
encouragement to somebody who's
uncreative is to maybe break up with
that term a little bit because
creativity in my mind is just making
stuff that um
changes something in some way yes it's
transformative it solves a problem
engineering is incredibly creative you
know art is creative there's lots of
different ways to think of creativity
and then look at your life
what are the things that happen to you
that are just weird
you know
weird stuff that happened to me um i won
the sixth grade spelling bee
and i beat an eighth grader and i made
him cry and that was the only damn time
i made an eighth grader cry
you bet your ass i felt good about that
and i found something that i could be
good at that that put other people down
as a twelve-year-old pudgy kid who had
long hair and was often mistaken for a
girl because i had bosoms
[Laughter]
that
was a good
thing for me to put i was like words i
can do things with words i can be
somebody yeah it was adapted and then i
kind of like worked through some trauma
and you know worked around the ego thing
a little bit but it was it it was a way
for me to you know make an expression of
myself in the world so you've got weird
stuff that other people don't have
harness that own the weird stuff and
then apply it to something that you want
to do
and then find somebody who's done it
right and go oh you're an author and you
write for an hour a day i never thought
of that i guess i'll try that because
you've got to kind of find your way but
take all your weird crap with you
because that's what's going to make you
you and it's going to make it unique and
then you still got to do all the work
you know you got to put all your hours
in it but you're taking that thing with
you that becomes your style and there's
this great quote from bono talking about
how they found that u2 sound and he said
you know
we were just trying to do what all the
other 80s bands were doing you know all
these hair bands and stuff and we
weren't that good
i mean the edge is not that great of a
guitarist he's a unique guitarist but
he's not steve vi
um
and he said and we weren't good enough
to do what everybody else was doing and
this sound that you call the u2 sound
that everybody's been copying ever since
is just what came out
and i think there's a surrender that
happens in the life of an artist where
you spend a good chunk of your life
trying to be your heroes
and you have to let that go and you go
this is what came out and eventually at
some point i'm going to own it hemingway
didn't invent the terse writing style he
was copying ezra pound and a number of
other people but he learned that
terseness from pound
in exchange for boxing lessons by the
way oh yeah oh wow yeah and um
and eventually you own what comes out
you go this is this is what this is what
came out you know and every musician
knows this you're like
nobody wants to hear the cover song like
i mean it's fun at a bar you know but
like you you don't want to make a
lifetime of creative artistry playing
other people's music you do that to
figure out what that feels like um i
think it was um
well fitzgerald used to um
uh copy you know the works of his
favorite authors instead of the hunter s
thompson hunter has thompson would write
the bible he would type it on a
typewriter and he said i mean it's a
bestselling book of all time i'm gonna
try it on peanut you know very hundreds
of things to do and he said he wanted to
write to see what it felt like what
those words felt like to his fingertips
so you copy other people as a way of
kind of take like learning the craft
yeah but then own all your weird [ __ ]
that makes that you can't outrun i can't
outrun all this weird stuff but i can
own it or i can try to push it off yeah
own all your weird stuff and this makes
me think about in high school i worked
at a wendy's this podcast is brought to
you by wendy's try a bacon double
cheeseburger today
how to clog your arteries yeah
oh man um
so uh me and josh and our friend pacho
and his brother jerome we had all these
weird voices we always did like just
kind of joking around with each other so
what i did to make my job fun at wendy's
i would take these weird voices and i
would use them through the drive-through
system that's amazing and like people
would come into the draft and be like
were you the guy i was just talking to
i'm like no no he's in the back
what you're talking about
that's creative anytime you do something
different
unexpected it's creative so all your
weird stuff is creative yeah what you're
really talking about here both of you is
expanding what you mean by creative
often people think they're not creative
because they can't write poetry
i can't write poetry but then the other
day uh professor sean over here was
telling me that no i a lot of your blog
posts are very poetic and i'm like i
never thought of it that way apparently
i've been writing poetry for years i
didn't realize it right but
if i narrowed it down i said well i'm
not creative because i can't do this one
thing just like when you were a kid your
mom said hey you're not athletic that's
one of the most creative things you can
do is play a sport right of course i
look at michael jordan i mean how cr
he's a creative genius right you look at
kevin durant i can't do what he does and
it's not all about height john stockton
he's in shorter than me mugsy bogues
there you go
right
he had to be creative that's the last
time i watched nba
1990 something yeah classic and the
point is he even he was he was
especially creative a five foot two guy
playing in the nba that requires a level
of creativity so adapt yes and so that's
what creating really is it's adapting to
some situation circumstance environment
doing something a little bit different
than how it's done before understanding
how it's done before
will durant speaking of durants whose
historian says
nothing is new except arrangement and so
my challenge is to anybody who would
think of what they do as creative or
uncreative
creativity is the act of rearranging
familiar stuff in an unfamiliar way and
people go
i never thought of it like that
you know the beatles were creative in
the sense that they were they were
putting together songs in ways that had
never been done before oh yeah and now
we look back on it like like
you know they went from mono to stereo
well like i mean that's nothing now but
at the time it was revolutionary that
there was a tambourine coming out of
this speaker and a voice coming out of
that one
oh yeah and like you listen to the white
album and half of it is like
these classic songs that are just gorg
and then the other half you're like what
the hell were they doing oh yeah drugs
right right lots of drugs and it's funny
because their their their producer was
like can we just like cut out half of
these songs and just make a hit album
they're like no we want the weird stuff
in there and that was the genius of the
beatles i think yeah you know is you got
love me do and then uh revolution number
nine number nine number nine number nine
yes and and you gotta get weird to get
good
and you've got to learn how to manage
the weirdness because the weirdness is
what's interesting it's the stuff that
comes out that you go hey that was
pretty good let's let's hold on to that
yeah
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
you